welcome to The Gadget Lab podcast I'm
Michael colori I'm Robbie Baldwin and we
have a special guest this week mr. Mike
Isaac hello Mike how are you doing today
well I'm fine guys how are you we're
wonderful haha paper bike Isaac in the
studio what's the story with this Ravi
so there's a new service that isn't even
in beta yeah it's called foldable dot me
and what it does it allows you to create
a version of yourself a little avatar
like Mike Isaac here and then you can
ship it anywhere for 12 bucks so you
know your mom misses you you can send it
to her it'll be scored and you know it's
really easy to put together this is
pre-beta so I had to actually build us
to myself and cut it out and is kind of
a pain but when they actually have the
the service up and running it'll be
ready to fold ready to put together and
put it by your computer or whatever
weird surprise the person by putting it
in there like you know poco I don't know
I was gonna say I was gonna make a bad
joke about making a little voodoo doll
out of it but I would never I would
never wish such arms upon our
illustrious a team member that might
guys it is so you did you have to take a
photo of him or did you just use a photo
that you dropped off of like one of his
websites or something I actually had a
photo of mike from from bumper cars
those was good times oh yeah we all we
all went road bumper cars pretty awesome
as a team-building exercise one day if
you work hard in school kids you too can
get a job where you get to go right in
public art this is pretty awesome so I
had a picture of Mike and I use that as
a frame of reference to to build like
it's kind of like building a nintendo
wii like a little Emmy character oh I
see so you know they basically all look
the same so if you're taller than
somebody else you know what do you do
just trim off the the bottom of it or
something maybe they're all the same
size there's no difference in height or
build so we all get the same build we
all get very large heads but just bikes
I have a large hit any large head anyway
so that's me too so they were built for
us well with Mike he'll complain that it
doesn't look exactly the kid because
he's smiling too much in this right yeah
a little too smiley so when you order
something up like this how much does it
cost do they know yet right there saying
12 bucks 1199 20 it's hard you mention
that okay so 12 bucks and they send it
anywhere anywhere yeah they said it'll
ship it anywhere it ships flat in an
envelope so you're not going to get like
a boxer male just get an envelope and
open it up bold but uh that's super cool
you know what's funny is I know that
like a lot of people have you know there
was the craze where everybody made their
their twitter avatar the Facebook avatar
look like a character from Mad Men uh
yeah and then there was the pixilated
version of you so now people are going
to be taking Instagram photos of their
little paper versions of themselves and
using is that that is their twitter
profiles I actually like that better an
Instagram of this unit I'm just going to
a website and building it out Ori
hipstamatic or hipstamatic app or a
twitpic are twitpic we don't want to
play favorites or anything is something
with a holga all right so by Mike thanks
for joining us earlier this week if you
have been reading The Gadget Lab blog
you will notice that Robbie did a test
of heat generated by our favorite
tablets where did this where did the
story idea come from so what happened
was Consumer Reports reported that the
brand new ipad brand new ipad at this
thing I'm sorry ipad 3 the three would
get up to 116 degrees if now here's the
the big if you played infinity blade for
45 minutes while it was plugged in now
if you think that's like a pretty
intense like 3d games yeah that's it's
an intense game and it's plugged in and
when you have something plugged in is
usually generating heat from the battery
so i decided to do the same test and so
I did the exact same chance I got to 108
degrees the ipad 3 plain infinity blade
for 45 minutes and i use this fancy heat
gun and so I got to 108 so then I
decided I'm like well let's find a
control app so i found an app that works
on iOS on android on blackberry even on
the kindle fire
and it is dead space and it's it's a 3d
shooter you run around killing creepy
monsters sighs are like
graphics-intensive yeah it's a graphics
intensive game that I also decided to do
it like how you play in the real world
very rarely do you play or use your iPad
wallets plugged in or tablet or kindle
fire unless you're like really low on
battery yeah Mr really long battery and
you still got like 45 minutes left of
you know Game of Thrones or something so
I did all the tests and it turns out the
ipad the new ipad and all you know the
the blackberry playbook and the samsung
galaxy yes the Asus Transformer Prime
they all pretty much had this within the
same range 92 about 97 98 degrees huh so
relatively cool yeah yeah and I talked
to it to a doctor at the burn unit and
he said you know 120 degrees if you're
submerged in water after five minutes
that will burn you but of course water
is surround you if you grab something
that's like 120 degrees it's not gonna
burn you right you're not going to be
like yeah grabbing the you know
something off the stove I've noticed it
like it feels warm to the touch yeah
it's only warm which is great we live in
San Francisco yeah I I know plenty of
times I've used when I use to have a
macbook pro and they would be cold i
would say to myself you know what i need
to do some work and I put into my lap so
that I mean that that does seem to be an
issue for some people they find it
uncomfortable to have a laptop
physically on their lap you know like
macbook air gets pretty hot a lot of the
ultrabooks get hot you know mostly just
because they have super thin cases and
they're going with aluminum and there's
less chance of vented dissipate the and
everything but with the tablet I mean
you're holding it in your hands yeah no
one does this it doesn't really seem
like heat would be an issue well I mean
I'm sure someone does but for the most
part when I use it I'm do this yeah this
and it's it's meant to be held yeah so
it seems sort of like a sort of like a
non-issue would you rate it isn't yeah
I'm saying it's a non-issue I mean it's
if I have infinity blade were available
on all of those tablets and I was able
to create like a actual experiment like
mr. control and they had all those
tablets plugged in i'm sure i could
probably get them up to about this
same temperature probably about 110
degrees well actually I think the
coolest part about this whole experiment
was that we came in possession of this
radio shack this is a what a digital a
laser thermometer where you point the
laser at any object in it it gives you a
digital readout on the screen of what
the actual temperature that of that
object is and it works up to I don't
know what 15 feet something like that
it'll-it'll it goes for a while yeah so
it's kind of fun so of course we spent
along a lot of time walking around the
office and walking around our homes
taking measurements of things the back
of my kha'zix real head the back of my
guys expand those were those rutube
there was like a three or four degree
difference we won't tell you which ones
hotter yeah but yeah lunch food burger
versus falafel yeah I went to McDonald's
and bust open a an apple pie and shot
the inside of that wasn't as hot as I'd
hoped really hot enough to burn though
right not really 120 degrees it was I
think they they're kind of there Tony
Tony down so it doesn't burn the inside
of your mouth speaking of burning the
inside of your mouth that's all the news
and all the time that we have this week
we will be back next week on The Gadget
Lab with more news more cool gadget show
you and maybe even more paper
representations of ourselves and then
when we left to you to decide which
version is real and which is the
simulacrum until then